how come some blind people wear sort of
Shades and some don't some blind people
have certain changes in the appearance
of their eyes they might go cloudy or
you know have different bits and mobs
going off right um like my eyes blink a
lot I don't know if you noticed
um you're that's got you in trouble a
little bit hasn't it like what's staring
yeah yeah but obviously I don't really
know where I'm looking a lot of the time
unless I'm talking to someone I know but
I'm talking to you so I'm trying to look
in your direction right
um like yeah I was in a gym
I've heard this story have you heard
this TV I think I sort of take it it's
so good can you share it with us yeah so
I was doing doing my exercises like a
good gym lad and um yeah my eyes just
when I'm concentrating especially they
will just fall wherever they want to so
yeah I was just staring straight ahead
and unfortunately there was a woman
doing some exercises don't know what she
was doing whether it was like some
squats or whatever where you know you
might be in a more vulnerable position
maybe yeah um you don't want to be
stared at so yeah she came over to me
and I didn't know she was talking to me
at first because I'm not doing anything
wrong I'm just you know doing my thing
as I said something along the lines of
why did you keep staring at me stop like
don't be so creepy I was like oh no I'm
sorry I'm blind had my cane with me it
was folded up on my lap yeah um
and yes she she didn't she wasn't having
any of it there's a there's a culture
isn't there around you know trying to
catch Out Gym creeps which I mean yeah
enough we don't want any creepy Behavior
anywhere but how about how is how is she
not having any of it when you've
literally got a cane like if you might
disguise mate so I can stare at women I
mean that is if you're a pervert right
yeah that you're the most committed
pervert in the world that's wild yeah
yeah no no so I think I don't know maybe
she just didn't clock it maybe she was
just really angry or uncomfortable at
the time and didn't clock it didn't
believe it wasn't having it yeah um
thought it was my water bottle I don't
know something like that who knows like
a like a fruit yeah like one of them
alcoholic
it's the most inconvenient shape
container for a drink I've ever seen in
my life so did that that did that
escalate yeah she said she'd go and get
the manager I don't think she ended up
getting the manager because it was a
really really young girl by the sounds
of it right
um I don't know yeah she just I think
she got caught in backed into a corner a
bit by this woman and asked me to leave
I was like I'm literally blind and I
wasn't as confident they asked you to
leave yeah they got me out of there no
way yeah yeah they got I I was in a
different place so the gym I go to now
I've got really good relationship with
all the staff they know me everyone in
the gym knows me as you know he's a guy
over can't keep out his way yeah um but
this was a new place I'd never been to
I've gone with a friend who was doing
exercises down the other end of the gym
so I didn't see any of this happening
um and yeah so the this young gym worker
you know just said sorry can you leave
we can't have other people being
uncomfortable oh my god did you ever go
back there
well I got loads of comments on this
video I've been like it's one of your
British things no but I feel like there
would be a case Fair I've had some
lawyers reach out to me as well really
represent you yeah wow maybe that's well
yeah well what do you mean yo we we
making people uncomfortable so you gotta
leave
nah you actively making people
uncomfortable but people are
uncomfortable around you therefore you
have to leave that's what it is this
feels like an onion article it really
blind man gets creeped it gets kicked
out of a gym for staring too long that
verbatim that sounds like a that sounds
like an onion article No Lie
deaf man gets kicked out of a hotel for
listening on another couple have sex
like it feels like it feels like one of
them once
the comedy writes itself
I go on I go on the stage I'd go on the
stage and I'd be like yo so
there's guys in the gym
and he's staring at the girl right
and the girl is like stop staring at me
the guy says it's blind
you just kicked out
all right that's all for me guys yeah
that wouldn't work on stage that would
work but still it's comedy it's crazy
it's just like yeah that it really
happens it's hard to even get upset
because I think it's just one of those
things where you know the first time I
saw the whole gym Obsession that women
had with like exposing creepers who
weren't actually even being creepy I
like that I had the energy then now I
just look at I'm like these crazy
[__]
I I get it there's dudes who do creep on
y'all and there's some weirdos at the
gym
and let's say you really thought that
was him I ain't even mad at you for
being like yo why are you staring but
when he says he's black and he has his
Cane on his lap just ask him to confirm
it and then keep it pushing you're done
goofed you assumed something that wasn't
happening
oh I know it will work knock knock who's
there blind man blind man who get the
[__] out Charlie apparently
apparently it's like and I suspect that
she knew he was actually blind she just
kept it going because she's too far gone
yeah it's like when someone says
somebody racist and then they come to
find out they're wrong they just keep
saying it and they want to act
incredulous because they they're all
amped up on emotions remember that girl
that she accusing this other guy that
she he stole her phone yeah and she was
looking in the purse it's not really
look
and she found the phone in her purse and
then she was like oh my God but it's
like she found it earlier she found it
earlier in the video yeah yeah because
she's already gone too far she can't
stop she can't stop there what's your
phone number let's bring that [__] up
let's go and then that ring in her purse
that's you gotta eat that you Hey listen
you know what's crazy is that little bit
of humility can create for a really good
experience and like a good bond with
somebody in a weird way like you just
went through something really weird and
you apologize or whatever you make a
human Connection in that way right into
that misunderstanding by trying to make
restitution and try to understand the
person you really discover like all
right I have these prejudices okay maybe
in the future I make better filters so I
don't ever engage in that behavior again
but instead of doing that we're so proud
during the ego it's like [__] that [__]
him even if I'm wrong you wrong it's
like that's stupid you think that young
girl did some type of affection she got
a not a manager but she's got an
employee kick him out no she went the
extra mile I mean I'm being generous I'm
uh who knows it might not even be that
she realized maybe she just convinced he
was a creeper and went all 150 I mean
she's stupid but that's just really done
to me someone pulls out okay you know
when he left he pulled out his Cane and
he did it so you must have thought he
was faking that too and then his friend
must have come over and said no he's
actually blind why are you guys kicking
out my friend so I don't know it's just
really dumb it's really really stupid
but yeah
this is what happens sometimes when you
go to a new gym and nobody knows you
especially if you're a peculiar person
or you got whatever going on sometimes
you get treated that way that's why a
lot of people who have disabilities like
their habits in their same spots because
they know there's a little bit of that
comfort of everybody already knows how
to work so yeah all this to say
even blind men aren't safe from being
called creepy even those I can't see
stop
ugly me [__] I got eyes I can't even
yeah but I've seen you staring at me
through your soul oh what the [__] [__]
my girl they're not working
you know that the eyes are the you know
the window of the Soul Masha got
shutters bro this [__] was wild but
let's see what you guys think in the
comments below we want to hear your take
what do you guys think also
y'all might not be blind but y'all can
see y'all can buy these tickets that's
right we're going on tour we coming to
cities near you we want to see you
[__] face to face where you at
we gonna be doing shows all summer this
summer we're doing three shows we're
doing Detroit Pittsburgh and Washington
DC but afterwards we were going to
England we're going to be going all
across America Asia so if you want to
get tickets make sure you guys go to the
website all right put your name so we
can email you as soon as those tickets
come out for your area we won't bombard
you with nothing else okay I promise
yeah
um we want to see you guys at the shows
we meet us we have meet and greets we're
gonna have a lot of fun we're gonna do
laughing so it's gonna be a good time uh
but we want to see you guys